Squeezie : Bonjour, j'espère que vous allez très bien.
McFly : Coucou.
Squeezie : Et vous est-ce que vous allez très bien ?
C'était la pire intro de ma chaine youtube.
Carlito : La plus faible
Aujourd'hui on est sur qui es-tu c'est un jeu sur PS4
Dans lequel on va jouer avec nos téléphones
Natoo/Carlito/Mcfly: T'as pris un accent de Vandamme
Et je précise aussi que c'est un jeu de la gamme
-Zelda
-De la gamme PlayLink, un jeu qui ce joue comme ça
-Parce que le héros s'appelle Link...
-Il va y avoir plusieurs thèmes...
-Enlèves ton fut
-Tu as dit quoi?
-Hein?
-Je crois que tu as dit "enlèves ton fut"
-Non je crois pas qu'il l'ai dit
-J'ai dit ça
Par exemple : un thème, le camping. il va donc y avoir  une question
par exemple : lequel de vous n'arrive pas a déplier sa tente?
On va devoir, chacun, noter le nom de la personne (-Ok) qui on pense...
-Qui on pense qu'il est le plus mauvais en camping
Voilà. Donc on y va c'est parti
(Rire) Regardes les photos!
-Ha les pires photos!
-Et Squezzie mec, c'est un vieil homme
-Qui proposerais des vacances dans un camp de nudistes (-Ho!)
-MAIS J'AI  PAS EU LE TEMPS DE VOTER
Deux d'entre vous gagnent des points
-Vous avez misé sur moi !?
-McFly, Natoo on voté sur toi
-Pourquoi 200, pourquoi vous avez des points?
-Parce que quand t'es dans la majorité, tu as des points
-J'ai pas compris, attendez qu'est ce qui viens de se passer?
-HOLALA! Qui profiterait de vacances en camping pour ne pas changer se sous vêtements ?
-Nan mais, tu m'écoutes même plus
(Rires)
Qu'est ce qui s'est passé avant?
-Y'as un complot de ce coté
-J'ai entendu enfoiré
-Là, essayez de m'expliquer sans s'énerver, hein,
Qu'est ce qui va se passer
-On va voir ce que les gens on jouer
-Natoo et moi on a dit que c'est toi qui changerait pas de sous-vêtements
Et Carlito et McFly on dit que c'était McFly qui changerait pas de sous-vêtements
-Mais comment tu sais?
-Bah parce que on sait qui a joué sur quoi
-Ca y est j'ai compris!
-Alors
- (imitation douteuse) Mais comment tu Sais (rires)
-D'accord, qui s'apercevrait trop tard qu'on ne caresse pas les loups
ça c'est mon nouveau fond d'écran, je préfère vous le dire
-Haaaaa!!! Il y a débat!
-Si je puis me permettre, pourquoi vous pensez que je caresserait un loup
-Tu sais pourquoi? Parce que comme t'es gameur, t'es un peu l'amour du risque
tu serais le genre à aller voir le loup et à dire c'est bon je le maîtrise
-Ca n'a aucun rapport, aller on continue!
-Et alors moi? Tous le monde s'en fiche!
(Rire) On est sur du manspreading, je vous le dis depuis tout à l'heure
Je suis maltraitée!
-Ho! Jeu de mots, jeu de mot les gars
-Là je pense que je peux gratter des points
-Squeezie dit "Hé, les campeurs, regardez un peu ...
Là j'ai l'impression d'être dans la vidéo qu'on avez fait la dernière fois, c'est horrible
-Mais tellement
-Oui!
-Hooo Noonn
-Mais moi j'ai pas terminer!
(Rires)
-C'est pas fini
-J'vote pour toi direct
-C'était Franck Dubosc avec le même slip depuis 10 ans
-Aller on vote tous pour Franck Dubosc
Jeu de photos
-Hé, vous connaissez un truc, y'a un endroit, où, quand on tape, ça ne fait absolument pas mal
Je te le fais regarde
-Ca fait hyper mal
-Pardon
-Carlito prends quelqu'un en photo
-On la reçoit sur notre téléphone et il faut la dessiner, après un mois dans la nature
-Quel enfant!
-C'est simple et efficace
-Putain, le mec c'est fait chier
-Hooooo! Stylée
Hyper stylée
-Qui rirait à une blague pourrie d'un prof?
-Bah bien sur...
-Mais oui
-Ha! Les enfoirés
-En art plastique, qui goûterait la colle
-L'heure de colle?
-Ou la vrai colle?
-Mais non, revenez
-Putain mais évidemment quoi
-Natto, t'es en dessous dans le score mais t'es au dessus dans le coeur
-Que ferait McFly si le prof sortait de la classe
-Il embrasserait un enfant mineur?
Pour moi, il deviendrait noir!
-Hoooo Tout le monde est d'accord
-Voilà
-Mais Carlito tu viens de perdre
-Carlito, il peut pas devenir noir!
-...Encore!
-Jeu en dessins, les amis s'il vous plaît un peu de sérieux
Dessinez ce qu'il y a dans le casier de McFly
-Un slip volant... Ok...
-C'est une... trottinette et un oiseau...
-Une kippa
-Une Kippa j'ai mis
-Il a fallu vraiment écrire
-Il a à rien fait
-Nourriture!
-Vous savez pas dessinez de la nourriture
-Hola! Jeu d'imitation?
-Alors bonjour, c'est Anne Roumanof
-Waaaaaaw Y'as Anne Roumanof qui est avec nous, c'est fou
-Imitez cette image
-Ho Pas mal!
-Mais vous avez les même yeux
-Hyper propre
(Rires)
-Ho c'est nul!
-C'est nul a chier
(Rires)
-Jeu d'image
-Quel animal représente le mieux
Moi, Carlito, en amour?
-Y'a un animal qui mérite tellement d'être sélectionner dans cette série
-Prends quelqu'un en photo pour pouvoir le dessiner avec un cadeau pour son rencard
(Voix jeu):Montrer moi un peu ce que ça donne
-Mais arrêtez de noter...mais... quoi? Qui a fait ça?
-C'est Carlito c'est sur
-Ho! Joli!
-Très bien!
-Joli le caca!
-C'est un petit cochon...
-Mais personne a voté pour mon cochon!!
Mon cochon il méritait hein?
-Oui, oui ressaisis toi.
-Ca va mec on est pas en primaire
-Je peux redire ma phrase de tout a l'heure? T'es en dessous dans le score mais t'es ..
Bah je la dis pas! T'sais quoi, j'la dis pas
-Quand ça fait un bruit sourd c'est que ça... Hoo!
-Il est rouge!
-Arrêter arrêter a un moment un peu de sérieux..
-Est ce que je peux dire ma phrase gentil pour Nathalie?
-Oui Bien sur
-Natoo, tu es...
Tu fais ce que tu veux avec cette info Nathalie, mais ça m'a fait mal...
Natoo tu m'as foutu une baigne
(Rires)
La Rihanna blanche! Aller salut!
-Quel rôle endoserait Natoo dans un braquage?
-Le rôle d'un braqueur, d'un braqueur, d'un braqueur, ou d'un vieux.
-Dessinez ce qu'aimerait le plus voler Natoo
-Mais on a une minute!
-On se met des claques en attendant?
-HA!
-Non mais stop, Non!
-Putain
-HA!
-Mais les gars!
-Cochon encore!
-Bah... Je veux que mon cochon gagne
-Attendez moi faut  que j'ex... Un gros avec un gros cœur
-Hoooo c'est beau
-Un poireauuuuuu
-C'est génial
-C'est bien
-Est ce que on veux faire une petite deuxième game?
-Ouiiiiiiiiiii
-N'oubliez pas! Des fois vous avez des joker vous pouvez les mettre et  ça double les point que vous gagnez
-Qui ne pourrait pas s'empêcher de désinfecter sa couchette avant de s'y installer
-Hooooooooooo
-Comment vous savez?
(Natoo)-Parce que t'es toujours propre
(McFly)-Moi je ne savais pas parce que moi je suis comme toi
-Ecoutes bien, quand je vais au chiottes quand c'est pas chez moi
Je sais où la femme de ménage range les produit ménager,
Et je vais nettoyer l'intégralité des chiottes
-(Sarcastiquement) Elle est bien ta vie
-Je dis pas qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas dire d'anecdote et tous dans la vidéo
-Mais en tous cas il faut qu'elle fasse au moins un tiers de cette durée là parce que...
Sinon ...
C'est méchant mais drôle
Qui essayerait d'organiser une fête dans le wagon-lit ?
Arrêtez de tricher
(cris) tu triches ils regardent
Que ferait natoo à un festival ?
Mais arrêtez de tricher
Quel train vous fait penser à natoo ?
Quel train vous fait penser à un humain ? Cette phrase est dingue
Arrêtez de tricher
Mais on a pas tricher
On a pas tricher regarde
Putaaaaiiiin mais non merde vous avez jouez la même chose
Je vais me mettre au milieu ça m'énerve
Tu bouges, Tu bouges
Fais gaffe aux petits chats
Squeezie prend quelqu'un en photo pour le dessiner en conducteur  de train